53 percent of 2020 Biden voters say he
shouldn't run 64 percent of Democrats
who voted for Sanders are worn in the
2020 primaries think he shouldn't run
and 76 percent of Voters under 35 think
he shouldn't run and what's the top
concern for that we asked voters we
didn't prompt them we said why don't you
think he should run well these were the
responses it almost is all about his age
and his ability to do the job I do
generally believe that at 82 years old
you should not be president of the
United States like it's just time to go
be a grandfather not that those
grandchildren want to be near him with
the sniffing of the hair and all that
stuff the idea that Joe Biden is going
to lead us to the other side of that is
so stagnated and so crazy and so it's
such a broken nonsensical idea that
again I think it's perfect for the
Democrats